[Music]
up next on c-span our new series book
notes each week at this time we bring
you an interview with the author of a
recently published book our guest this
week bruce otis editor of from the
president richard nixon's secret files
[Music]
bruce otis
author of from the president richard
nixon's secret files
here's a photograph i'm not sure you've
even seen before in time magazine and if
you look closely right where my finger
is is your book
oh really i hadn't noticed that sitting
on the president's desk
uh as he sits around and talks to some
of his advisors during the john tower
episode what's what's what's the impact
on you when you see that picture
well you're seeing the impact because i
hadn't realized that
the
the president had a copy on his desk i
have assumed so for some time but
doesn't it's not surprising at all
and i think what he realizes is that
we are moving into a new generation of
communication between president and the
people
as a result of an act that was passed 10
years ago called the presidential
records act which makes
these presidential uh documents uh
public property oliver north's papers
whatever we say about them were
government us government property they
were not the private property
of uh
president reagan and you know the the uh
papers of all of our presidents from
george washington up until richard nixon
were
were private property and
it was because of watergate nixon's
resignation and the thought which was
then widespread the assumption on the
part of congress that
the
nixon would probably destroy many of the
records of his administration that
congress in 1974
seized
his papers just in a process that's
condemnation process much like
one might seize some land
for a superhighway or something like
that it's very abrupt and we're dealing
with the consequences of that
to this day and perhaps in legal terms
mr nixon's attorneys and we may be
dealing with that for quite some time to
come but the upshot of
all of this the implications are
enormous because after
richard
nixon took
his
case
challenging that
action by the congress
uh to the
through the courts it was upheld by the
supreme court in 1977 and then
the congress and jimmy carter wrote in
some of the
language um
of the court some of the ideas the
concepts of exceptions
to
the documents some of the rules the
administrative rules i suppose is the
phrase but in in the
handling of these documents into the
presidential records act of 1978
and
the national archives and records
administration is
in the process right now and continuing
process of trying to
administer and understand this act and
its implications as of course are all
presidents so what's happening is that
george bush to get back to your question
is
has
is creating a record
on a daily basis
that will be open if he loses in 92
to the public in
when his presidential library opens in
1995. let me go back though before we go
any farther for those people just tuning
in
what's in this 661-page book
many of the memoranda written by richard
nixon and
by members of his staff
during the course of the nixon
presidency how did you get it i went
down to
the archives
annex and pickett street in alexandria
rather
nondescript
warehouse where they're presently being
stored
and
began working with these documents in
the summer of 1987 when they were
released
when richard nixon decided not to
further contest
the release of
these documents how many memoranda or
memorandums are there in there in this
book
uh well a lot
and one way of looking at it if a member
of the public were to go down there and
start pulling out
of the
boxes and ordering up reproduction
copies of
the pages
in this
the reader would spend more than five
hundred dollars
in reproduction user feed charges alone
for these documents
and so it's a bargain if that at the
price if i can get in a
sales pitch
but what i did what i saw first of all
is that simply that richard nixon
whether you love him or whether you hate
him is one of the most prolific writer
writers of memoranda
in the uh history of the presidency and
i i tend to feel he's
still a champion to this day
he
dictated
in some days as many as
um
two to
three dozen memos in a single day
and or single night or weekend he
usually worked nights and weekends and
he wrote these in a burst
it would dictate
a number of them of course the system
now has changed in the white house a bit
it's
much of
what was done in hard copy in nixon's
time
is now run through computers
but
and word processors but
still there's a lot of hard copy
material and being generated in the
white house
and um
it provides a very precise
uh record of
what happened and essentially what this
book has is the the
core of it
is better than 95 percent i would judge
of
the
memos
written by mr nixon that have been
released to date uh
your book has 95 of the memos right that
have been released today i looked in all
of the places that uh
were most likely in those archives keep
in mind they released 3.2 million pages
in 1987 and i've been through i haven't
been out through all 3.2 million pages
i've been through many hundreds of
thousands of pages
but it was simply not physically
possible i do continue to find as i
continue to work at the archives
a memo uh
written by nixon that uh
on very rare occasion once every three
or four months now but the the great
bulk of them are in
in this book and then of course on top
of that what we saw after we looked at
the memos were a lot of very interesting
staff memos
and written by primarily uh patrick
buchanan and charles coulson and h.r bob
haldeman and so the logical way to
deal with that simply was to
arrange them in
in chronological order and they tell a
story that way of a presidency from
beginning to end and
in nixon's case of course in the case of
several of our recent presidents it was
not particularly uh happy ending
but
you do build to a
climax of
considerable dimension in
the early summer of 1972
late spring with
the watergate break-ins and there there
was a great deal of paper that flowed
through i tried to leave as much of that
paper flow get as much of that into the
book as possible particularly from
those first six months of 1972.
what happened is that after james mccord
started to sing
as it were tell his story to the courts
in may and april of i believe it was of
1973
richard nixon simply stopped
dictating
memoranda i think there were two in the
final 16 months of his presidency and
i've checked with the archives
there are no further nixon memoranda to
come out from that period
there are some others
from the earlier period
that will come out many are being
still held of course for national
security classification reasons
and then there's
the other concept which is
the fact that mr nixon requested in 87
that 150 000 pages
be withheld
and
the archives for
under under reasons which are
granted in effect
by the
supreme court in its 1977 ruling and the
archives
rather than challenge that
went along with that request and
is on
a
temporary basis pending the outcome of a
review that is uh now underway is due to
be completed sometime i gather before
the end of this year
let me uh change something a little bit
where are you from
well i
was born in chicago and grew up there
and
went to
northwestern where i majored in
journalism
and
the idea of
doing a book like this really grows out
of my
my background and experience in
journalism and i think it's a
somewhat new concept we've had books
before by historians of
of documents of
truman's letters or various presidential
papers often
long after the fact and uh
not edited to try to tell this whole
story of the presidency as much as
this is and i
would dearly have loved to have had this
on the market also one uh on jimmy
carter by
the time of the
1988 election but that just simply was
not physically possible
but the that concept grows out of out of
that and i've spent time i was
in the foreign service overseas in the
1960s and promoted twice i wanted to
learn what the inside the paper flow the
bureaucracy i suppose that was my my
fascination
and then i've been back in washington
and living in the washington area for
the last
nearly 20 years now what do you do when
you're not writing books
i spend my time in archives looking at
documents did you ever work for a
newspaper i worked i covered
africa for the chicago daily news and
time magazine in the late 60s and
then
once i came back
i spent some time at columbia university
under
what was at that point their equivalent
of the neiman program
in 6970 and then i've been freelancing
in washington ever since i
sold pieces to
you name it
i've sold it there and i've
for the last decade or so as i've been
poking around i'm working primarily on
on a book on richard nixon's foreign
policy and in a sense
uh this was a spin-off from that project
i was
there when they
heard uh
came in
the press
during uh
at the opening of the time these papers
were opened in 1987.
i was
there quietly working on my nixon
foreign policy book and i expected that
at least the major news organizations
would assign someone who would
or a team of reporters
who would sit down and sift through
these
papers for a series of articles that
would be produced on a
fairly orderly basis
given all of the fascination with
richard nixon and his
secret files and uh one thing in another
and instead what happened was uh they
came in uh stayed for
one two or three days and everybody left
and i was there alone working on my book
all by myself and i said well here's all
these presidential memoranda
certainly someone needs to
get this out in the public domain
and i think anyone who reads this book
fairly carefully can figure out from him
his or herself
if they're a journalist
precisely
what kinds of articles that
one might produce for a series a
newspaper series
that could have appeared in 1987
but this didn't happen i mean one could
have done an article on
uh nixon's memos what he had to say then
there's there's other things the fact
that the
plumber's papers uh
nine boxes 230
file folders um are missing have not
been seen since 1974 were supposed to
have been released in 1987
but we still don't have even a
determination by the uh
justice department for all i know that
that these might have been
illegally uh
shredded or stolen
and
i don't
know that they've even launched a
criminal investigation in this i mean
oliver north is accused of
pretty much the same thing and he's
admitted his shredding we know
what happened there but
there were plenty of stories in other
words to go at and one of the other
stories was of course the fact that
inadvertently the the archives
managed to release
some of the pages that richard nixon
would have preferred to be withheld like
well i've carefully marked them in
in the book
so the the reader can go through and
decide for himself which he thinks
should have been
withheld and rich which richard nixon
might have been overreacting on you
marked the ones that uh
uh they're indicated there if you begin
from the very beginning at the very
first memoranda that i use in the uh
in the book after the editor's note
you'll see that the
this one
that one there is a one is a memo that
richard nixon asked to be withheld
and um
this is so indicated if we can flip over
sure um
here if you see where my finger is
right there
what's it say there
it says
withdrawn from ppf1 at the request of
richard nixon
ppf1 means president's personal file box
number one at the request of richard
nixon however uh you find a
copy of that memo in
h.r haldeman's files box 229
now you can
i
happen to have reasonable grounds for
believing that to be the case from the
simple technique that i employed which
was to
obtain also a photocopy of the
list of documents that
nixon asked to be
withheld and so i know
the date of a particular document that
requested be withheld who it's from who
it's to what the subject matter is or at
least the first three words of the
the memo in question and from there
there is a 99.99
certainty when one finds a memo which
fits that description that it is uh
uh the um
memo in in in fact and i've
uh have confirmed um
from my sources in the archives that uh
they were
aware that some might be seeping
through but they were asked to do this
process of removing 150 000 pages from
this 3.2 million page collection in a
space of a very few weeks and of course
by the time richard nixon was president
the
photocopying technology was was
widespread and there were just copies of
these things all in several boxes harper
and roe published this how did you
convince them to do it
well
actually was my agent who did so but
they
they were intrigued they showed them
examples of the memos and they had
no problem whatsoever
in reaching a decision that it was time
to
publish this stuff back in 87 you talked
about the press coming in for a couple
of days can you remember that how many
people you saw going through the memos
um
there were quite a few actually the days
when the the there is the heaviest
concentrations i tried to stay away i
would
ask when the archivist you know the
collection is opening on monday and
tuesday
and i would call up and says how bad is
the mob in the room and she says oh
we've got a full house today
and then i said well i'll come in on
wednesday i'd come in on wednesday and
they were they were pretty much gone i
did see a few people going through but i
gather it was it was quite a scene and a
scene worth covering in and of itself
you almost have a television camera in
there covering it because
what you get there's a room
with let's see what is it one two three
four five about nine tables there
and one
uh desk for the archivist to
sit there overseeing the room and the
handling the papers have to be handled
of course in a
rather careful fashion
but one got the wire services in there
and everybody getting all
excited you know here i've got one i've
got a hot one
and somebody else you know trying to
keep each other and and these boxes have
to be handled in a certain in a manner
and of course they're all on deadline uh
having to file before the day is out and
trying to figure out when to file and
all of that process
which you can understand now i you know
the wires are the wires i've i worked
for city news bureau in chicago a little
bit before psy hirsch did
so i understand the problem of the wire
services i've had to i remember in after
my days in africa i uh had to sometimes
walk through the night to the single
cable office in town when a taxi
couldn't be found but it seems to me
with
presidential papers that
it would be appropriate for the
press to
really take someone who perhaps say
covered the nixon administration the new
york times for instance sent
john finney there to head its team
but uh
they took a look at this volume of paper
and realizing that the 150 000 pages
which were withheld they were and i do
think there's there's a lot more to be
found in those 150 000 paper pages but
then they didn't do the logical thing
was to say well well let's let's take a
look and see what is there anyway are
you glad
well i'm glad in the sense that i was
able to get a book out of it sure
but uh you know there's an irony in all
of this remember that the new york times
during the
pentagon papers dispute which remember
the pentagon papers in 1971 were
primarily agency documents
state department pentagon what have you
they were not
lyndon johnson's presidential memoranda
by any stretch of the imagination
and everyone got all excited about the
release of these and
richard nixon certainly overreacted and
but
at that time
but the argument of the times and
publishing those i think was absolutely
correct there was no question with times
washington post and others once a
bureaucrat had a government employee had
made the decision
to put these out the press should not be
responsible for
determining whether given documents a
set of documents that is given are the
release of those is authorized or
unauthorized that's something for
government to
take care of
itself
but it seems to me that it is
appropriate for the press which uh
thrives certainly on unoff the release
unauthorized release of materials
and sits in a courthouse for instance in
oliver north day after day looking for
another document or two
to at least give
serious treatment to
major releases of presidential materials
and
you're not going to have
[Music]
very many more newsworthy figures uh
newsworthy releases and materials and
then the special files of richard nixon
remember that and
and this leads to the next question i'll
take it right out of your mouth
but these files were created in
september of 1972
by uh
upon nixon's instructions
the materials physically were taken out
of the white house central files and
were located into a what was called the
white house special files
now that meant that when their inquiries
from congress or whoever
about what the white house records
showed
in 71 and early 72
or later
that the white house could respond
that well nothing is to be found on
subject x in
the white house or we're giving you
everything there is to be found on
subject x and
the white house central files meanwhile
of course all the good stuff would be
over in in the white house
special files
and so therefore there was an enormous
interest when this was
discovered during the watergate period
that the special files had been created
it's meant
that you had an enormous interest in
this particular file
richard nixon has incidentally
done the same thing once again with
another round of this by
identifying these 150 000 pages now out
of the 3.2 million as
the hottest stuff and so i'm sure
the mob has no choice but if and when
those 150 000 pages are released
um
that is the other 99 that i don't have
in my book
um
to to be down at the archives and and be
there i hope i think we've been
marvelous for c-span just to cover the
scene in that research room when the mob
goes in there i think the nation would
howl with laughter when's it going to
happen
um
that's a very good question if
richard nixon decides not to sue
let's see the review process let me back
up for a second
the review process will continue
throughout the course of this year and
presumably
the archives i would guess
review panel will probably agree with
richard nixon
in nixon's conclusion that is the
conclusion of his attorneys on perhaps
10 percent or so
of 150 000 pages
um
and richard nixon's people in turn may
agree with
the archives on uh
perhaps uh 10 or so of the materials and
there will be a
[Music]
disagreement on perhaps
a substantial majority the whole perhaps
60 70 80 percent we don't know
um at that point richard nixon has to
decide whether to uh
sue
challenging the judgment of the archives
if he doesn't
then these in turn will come open at
some point presumably next year
let me go back to this photograph here a
minute for those who may have just
joined us we're talking about a book
that bruce otis has edited
and uh and we opened the program up by
showing this photo that you'll see on
your screen here in just a second
you'll see a picture of george bush and
senator warner but right here is your
book i know you haven't seen this before
but i guess what i want to ask you is if
this president reads this book about
what another president had to say
about his day-to-day activities what
impact in your opinion will it have on
it
well i hope a positive one you know
george bush can handle all of this very
very uh well
um
what will he learn from it
well he's got he's got a series of three
things he has to deal with
perhaps some decisions uh on the pa the
nixon papers obviously
he knows mr nixon they they're very
close they talk presumably quite
regularly and
i i would feel certain that mr nixon
would discuss
with president bush the question of a
lawsuit or how to handle these things
one could create it could be time for
instance for
uh nixon to um
as i've proposed in my introduction that
it's time to make a little piece of it
can the president who
went to china and had the taunt with the
soviet union not make peace with the
united states government over his own
documents it would seem rather ironic if
he should leave this world not having
come to some kind of arrangement we have
to remember that a nixon library is
being built in yorba linda california
will be opening at the end it's an
unauthorized library if you will it's a
not one in which the national archives
will be as participating and that will
be opening at the end of
1990 the end of next year followed by
president reagan's
which is to be dedicated i believe on
his uh the 80th birthday in february of
91.
now um so bush has and there's a
president he knows that his own records
are being
our public property and he has there's a
lot of implications and
how to to handle all of these
but essentially in terms of dealing with
the nixon records he can uh simply uh
it would seem to me if mr nixon is
willing to explore some kind of
compromise solution remember there's a
lot of nixon undeeded materials
um
that the archives
would certainly love to
have permanently there's a lot of things
on both sides of the
question i mean nixon does hold some
some cards in such a such negotiation
that are in storage in places like
laguna miguel california and
elsewhere
materials going back to his tenure as
vice president he's also sued for
compensation for the seizure of his
documents and the us government could
quite
well wind up paying many millions of
dollars to richard nixon in compensation
there's a lot of issues here at stake
and i should think that an appropriate
device political device would be for the
the president to suggest designate the
national archives
as the
which is the lead agency in this to deal
with
nixon's representatives and
representatives of the congress i think
which would be very important here um to
sit down and try to hammer out some kind
of reasonable solution to stop this this
legal wrangling which has gone on so
long
if that can be done with the
nixon
papers
then i would think they could take a lot
of steam out of the
possible issue of secrecy obviously one
can build a case you know the democrats
of the party of openness and the
republicans of the party of secrecy so
to speak and i think
bush can
buy some adroit
action here
prevent that from uh
coming to that kind of an impasse but in
terms of to get back to
the implications on his own uh
papers
um
we've had everything on the light stuff
to date so far we've seen we've not just
had the john tower question but we've
also had
the decision and perhaps there's a memo
somewhere in the white house about the
decision to build a horseshoe pit or uh
millie's puppies perhaps you know we've
had the questions of nancy's astrologer
there is a lot of light stuff in there i
didn't
uh
i chose things that were not only
serious but things that were
amusing for this uh uh selection because
i i do seek
an audience that is wider than just
simply
uh
academia let me grab one here's august
two i just opened it up august 12 1972
from the president this is written by
richard nixon correct it says from the
press okay right to h.r holdem and his
chief of staff
covering some odds and ends
milton pitts the barber has indicated on
a couple of occasions that he would very
uh he'd be very glad to go to florida
during the period of the campaign at his
own expense apparently he has a brother
who lives in miami and he would like to
go down and visit him for a few days my
guess is that this is probably for
personal purposes as much as anything
else but it occurred to me
having taken his predecessor down
and if we have the room that you might
have it arranged for him to go down on
one of our planes not mine but under but
the understanding that he should not
indicate that he is going down for the
purpose of providing any services for me
it goes on and on and on why did you put
that in there
because it uh is readable because it is
substantive and uh the memo goes on i
think doesn't it for quite a long time
oh yeah it's a very long amendment right
it starts to read the whole thing but it
talks about the barber and i just
wondered if if that was one of the more
humorous things you that you had some
irony in that uh
well in that specific one i the only
ones that we did not choose there were a
handful of the ones that nixon wrote
that
were of
a strictly purely administrative nature
now this one is a very long one you'd
have to read the whole thing
to
look into what else he was saying but
nixon some some of these were you know
several thousand words in length that
just cut any of the memos down
themselves um i think one or two and
we've indicated where one or two are
have been shortened a little bit but
we've kept in the uh
the substance uh here's another one
august 5th this one's from charles
coulson to ken claussen who was a press
aide right
couldn't we do better than this question
mark it is incredible to me that this is
all we have gotten out of charlton
heston
right we see campaign techniques uh it
was
deeply of deep concern to me that i
regretted that we couldn't have this out
during the time of the campaign last
year
because we see uh
firsthand the
people inside the white house
handling the 72 campaign i mean this is
one way to describe this book is this is
a view from
inside the fort
in the
american civil war the 20th century and
we've never really seen the view from
inside we've all we've seen in the press
everything else has been written about
it is either
a single view from inside this which
those memoirs are always self-serving or
we've
seen the press accounts from outside the
barricades we haven't really seen
materials from from the inside one of
the things that could be done
that hasn't been done you know to date
with the campaigns i think the most
logical thing
we provide a lot of money for the
presidential candidates
to conduct their campaigns and there
have been several good ideas as to what
could be done and one of which i would
strongly favor which would be
no public monies to be used for those
30-second or one-minute
commercials that the only public money
could be used for something at least
five minutes in length
and that would seem to me the beginning
of wisdom but another
uh technique that could be used is
saying that any candidate for for the
presidency who accepts public money it
should also be required to put the
papers of his campaign uh collect and
save them and not destroy them and turn
them over to the archives for release to
the public there are techniques in other
words political techniques which can be
used
to if not end the kind of nonsense that
took place during the campaign last year
at least limited to uh
much uh
change the rules of the game a bit for
the better for the public all concerned
as you read through this book
one name that keeps coming up all the
time
is lou harris
oh you've uh you you're the first person
to uh
uh
call attention to that one
we've only used i've only used part of
the lou harris memos there are a lot
more over there in alexandria if anyone
who
is wondering about it i found it one of
the most fascinating
aspects of the 72
campaign lou harris of course is a
pollster and
he was
putting out some polls in
70 and 71 i believe it was that they
were very
that nixon thought were uh rather unfair
didn't cast nixon in as fairlight as
possible
so what happened was a campaign to
put a bit of political arm on mr harris
um he was stroked on the one hand a
trip to moscow invitations the white
house that kind of thing but by the same
token it's very clear in these memos and
materials that
he was also threatened with the loss of
the contracts that he held with some
government agencies
and
it is certainly for mr harris himself to
to say how much he was or was not
he felt influenced by all this pressure
but you see from the documents
themselves the fact that there was
considerable pressure and that he
certainly in his responses to the white
house
seemed to uh
change his attitude quite substantially
um how's the 4072 campaign how unhappy
is lou harris about all this being
published do you have any idea i've
never met the man of that no contact i
have no idea whatsoever and you get an
impression when you read that he was
known as a democrat had worked in the
kennedy years i believe early and in
these memos and then and you you see
even at one point you see pat buchanan
getting upset that chuck coulson seems
to curry favor with lou harris and that
he's being he's he's fooling himself
into thinking that he's going to be
right but trust turned him around right
right
uh i appeared on the today show speaking
of chuck colson with him on
february 15th and i was delighted to see
that he gave a very good commercial for
the book but
afterwards he said well he was
as he signed a copy of the book for me
he said that
he was glad
to see that there were a few memos of
his that i hadn't found i asked him
which ones and he said
that they were
ones in which
he and buchanan were planning this
a campaign to get the president's
attention and change his mind on a few
things that he and pat felt were
important and get around haldeman the
so-called german wall
the uh through the the staff
the staff layering
at the white house i i can't see
particularly what's so uh
of such great concern about that why he
would want to keep those out but
for instance when so much else is out
but
i'm uh he did happen to mention that uh
that to me any any reaction from richard
nixon himself about this uh no and i
would i would certainly welcome it i
sent him a copy of the book together
with a letter uh
the first day i received my first copy
and i know that his office
knew that i was working on the book in
fact i discussed it with john taylor his
aide
when nixon was in
washington in april of 19
last year 1988
i mentioned that i was working on the
book
one of the other things that comes
through is that
in some of these memos is that there
were those inside the white house who
were
aids to richard nixon who he personally
kept referring to in the memos
in less than a positive light
that they weren't really on his side
leonard garman seems to come to mind in
that process
in the relationship with the media
you keep reading about herb klein being
on the other side of where chuck coulson
was with the media
what else did you see in there
well there are a number of those cases
and klein certainly did take his lumps
as we know left the administration
uh early on but the relationship i've
seen them on a couple of occasions
certainly continues to this day seems to
be
perhaps the publication of this will
help re-establish a
more warmth in the relationship
klein certainly has remained quite loyal
to nixon throughout
his career
and in his own book klein
is critical of a few things that
happened in the 60 campaign and you know
herb klein is probably right in all of
these things and i think if as richard
nixon looks back at what
klein
did and was saying and the point of view
he was taking on 72 he would have to
realize now
that klein was
really correct in
in his interview with nbc in april of
uh 88
nixon suggested at one point that he
probably had been too rough on the press
it was quite an admission
and and that that was true i mean
nixon it was a carrot and stick
technique uh that nixon used on the
press you know it was nixon who created
the improved conditions of the white
house for reporters and there was a lot
of courting of the press but by the same
token nixon really used more of a stick
than had ever been used before in the
press the des moines speech in
69 that was
really written
i suppose by buchanan primarily for
and
next against through agnew delivered the
speech
but
it was a carrot and stick technique that
was applied and
there are
to a certain degree that's going to
continue i'm sure it continues
in the bush administration to this to
this day
but there are limits it seems to me that
to the
extent of the technique and one of the
most amazing discoveries i made during
the course of doing the book was that
well what we knew is that their dirty
tricks were used against the political
opposition during the
72 campaign
and we knew that nixon hated the press
but we didn't we haven't really known
and we've suspected that there may have
been dirty tricks used against the press
but not until i see these documents do
we really know
that dirty tricks were in fact used
against the press
and the dirty trick the procedure
specifically was the use of
disinformation black propaganda against
the press a
network anchors uh or dan rather john
chancellor or someone walter cronkite
would say something that was not
particularly appreciated in the white
house
the
white house would then
get out a suggested letter or telephone
call memo which would go over to the
republican national committee
and then the republican national
committee would
contact its friends around the country
and these people would contact nbc cbs
abc
and say that
you know express their opinion on a
given
subject
without telling nbc cbs abc
that
they were doing so upon the
explicit instructions of of the white
house many of these people didn't know
that it was the white house that was
doing it they thought it was the
republican national committee perhaps
they could be
they were a bit naive in their own mind
but i think that's that's really
grossly unfair it's really a
lack of civility
in the relationship between press and
politician to uh
for the politicians to use on a
systematic basis
that technique
the technique in of itself is the kind
of thing that on an informal basis
we would use almost every day
you know
we're sitting here talking and you say
tell me that there's somebody else does
something
that you don't like i might say to you
well
write him a letter and call him
that's perfectly normal technique but
when as
was the case in the nixon administration
the president orders
as he did in 1969 the summer of 69 a
specific program to be organized on an
organized basis to do this kind of thing
regularly and routinely on a large scale
and to do it to the press
i think as it
goes over the the boundary the the line
of propriety and civility that we're
trying to uh
uh
nixon's the line at the time as you
recall was it was lower our voices and
now it's kinder and gentler but it was
lower our voices was a slogan 20 years
ago and
that wasn't really a way to lower our
appropriate way to lower our voices what
most surprised you about richard nixon
in reading these memos
well i can't say that i was surprised by
the
the uh
depth of his intellect i find him one of
the most fascinating american presidents
of this century i think he'll be
remembered as that
that's why i think it's correct is one
reviewer has said that nixon
lovers will love this book and nixon
haters will will love this book also um
there's this
an incredibly uh
organized ability to
to
see
see himself as a as a third person um
look at himself
and and be interested in the marketing
of that third person
uh to an extent and this is perhaps true
goes back to his birth in california
the fact that he
was always been interested in the movies
from an early age
and
so therefore he
developed
an interest
in the in the media from a very early
point
in his
in his school years and in fact took a
journalism course at whittier college
which stephen ambrose
looked at the grades discovered he got a
c in journalism his freshman year and
maybe that's the the origins of
his uh his problems with the press
but
i think if
nixon thinks back on his career and i
think
i've suggested if i
in my cover letter to him that one of
the things he should do for
for posterity's sake
would be to do an essay of a length that
he would deem appropriate
on the press and its appropriate
relations
appropriate role in a democracy
he's
he's talked about the press complained
about it throughout his political career
sometimes spoken diplomatically of it at
other times spoken very harshly of it
and it really would be very helpful
to historians and i think serve a
contemporary purpose if he were to
set aside
for a moment all of
his his work on foreign policy and do a
a
serious essay on
what are the limits and what should be
the limits of
the
relationship
of the politician to the press
um
that i think is is
a very central thing as i'm working on
his foreign policy obviously there are
few
bits and pieces that come
through in nixon's memos
i
find there nothing you know his nixon's
contention that he would have been able
to do a great deal more in the middle
east had he
been allowed to finish his second term
there's nothing that i've seen so far
that would dispute that contention let
me ask you about this memo right here um
what did it strike you as being strange
at all that this memo came from the
president
to mrs nixon
in the memo he refers to himself as the
president
um
right now there's
mr nixon may wish to maybe someone will
ask him about it someday but um
i would make two observations on a memo
like that
one that it in all likelihood was
dictated late at night in
some very busy times when he's trying to
get a lot of things done and get
organized and get things moving in the
white house
and
so
he also had a lot of things that mrs
nixon was was doing to help him
get organized
and so the
memo was dictated in the third person
because she was then going to be dealing
with the uh gsa director and therefore
all it would she would need to do would
uh be to change re-route the the memo to
the gsa director without changing the
language
so it was it was maybe an example of the
efficiency the administrative efficiency
that
is certainly an aspect of
richard nixon that's an important one to
remember remember it was not only h.r
halda but it was very efficient hamilton
jordan i have to interrupt here to say
hamilton jordan during jimmy carter's
administration
failed to
date
many of the memos that he wrote
president carter i mean i
found this out relatively recently and
the archivists i think we all should all
be appalled by mr jordan's
failure to to do that
one thing you have to say about bob
holliman is he was extremely efficient
perhaps efficient to to a fault
but it was richard nixon who
who wanted and helped and cultivated a
bob halton to be his chief of staff and
so nixon does have a turn of mind that
insists upon administrative efficiency
and we'll note that in that memo
going back to that memo again
that
raised in there i believe the question
of having two dictaphones
by his nightstand
and
was again an example of the organized
the organization in his mind one of
course was for current government
business
uh to be transcribed and the other was
to create his uh
his diary
which uh
those tapes were were not transcribed
uh but were he took them from the white
house with them and those are one of the
things that
we certainly must all hope that he will
deed to the nation so that
in
in their entirety so that we can
someday
be able to study him that much more
closely let me ask you about uh a sense
that you you may have gotten from
watching this thing up closely
after you read all these memos did you
get a sense that the president
set the mood and that all the age around
him were marching to his tune or vice
versa
richard nixon ran the nixon
administration there was
a lot of press interest and speculation
in the question for instance henry
kissinger's influence
and importance on foreign policy and
henry kissinger was influential and very
important
in gerald ford's foreign policy
and he certainly would get a point in or
two with richard nixon but
as i'm sure dr kissinger will
acknowledge
he
[Music]
richard nixon set the tone for foreign
policy in the nixon administration and
henry kissinger was simply a spear
carrier
what's the name otis
well it comes from
in french it would be pronounced ood
and i had an ancestor who was a
coachman
in napoleon's army
who defected
on the way to moscow and
settled in central europe and then in
early in this century my grandfather
came to the united states and that's
settled
in the
chicago area
how many copies did they print on this
the first printing
uh 35 000 of which the first printing's
about sold out i understand i think
there's going to be a decision shortly
to go to a
second printing you get any sense of
what kind of people bought it
a variety of people i've been around to
a number of bookstores
you have
for college students or for college
faculty members first of all there's a
this is an excellent tool to
one can just assign this book to a class
in
modern american politics and say
you know do you think richard nixon
should really have been impeached
and the articles of impeachment in fact
are at the back of the book so one can
go through there and aft read all the
memos and then read the articles or
re-read as the case may be the articles
of impeachment
and um
so it's designed for serious as a tool
to help serious academics but it can
also easily be a coffee table book one
can
just read if one has a few minutes a
few memos and pick up the book a few
days later it's not as though you're
getting engrossed
in a
a
dense
historical tome that is
very difficult to
pick up again once you've put it down i
mean
this book
could be and should be i think read
through
very
seriously from front to back but
one can sort of delve into it
and
just
look through it on a lighter basis
should one get a sense over on this
other page right across here you you run
throughout this book and and and various
times uh editorials from the grant
county press petersburg west virginia
is this your way of giving us what you
thought about this at this time
well not really in a sense i think it's
much more objective than that um
the uh
problem of richard nixon was and the
question of impeachment
and his
the decision on resignation came about
when he finally
lost the support
of the republicans in the senate
who could have blocked uh
uh an impeachment and a on a vote
and it's very important for readers to i
think to understand that and remember
that it was not just there was no
question but that
the witch hunts that were launched that
were taking place inside the white house
begat witch hunts out outside the white
house
and that richard nixon one talks about
richard nixon's paranoia well he had
reason to believe certainly after 72 and
73 that a lot of people were were after
him the question of whether he was
paranoid or not during 73
is
certainly one to to discuss they really
there were a lot of people he was quite
accurate in that regard
but it was as as these revelations
unfolded in 73
editors around the country of small
weekly newspapers
were
and and others people around the country
suddenly had to realize that this was a
very serious thing this wasn't just
a new york and washington uh media event
and
that
there was some serious anguish going on
in the country and i have a
farm in
grant county west virginia and
alice welton happened to be a longtime
editor of the paper of its republican
roots uh
abe lincoln's
mother was
said to have been born nearby
and
it's a republican enclave in a state
that is two to one democratic
and
i remembered as i went through these
documents
that uh
alice had printed
some editorials in 73 and and so i got
the idea of going back
uh
to me at the time it was when i first
realized the depth of richard nixon's
difficulty i would commute from
washington out to west virginia
and it was not until i read the press
and read what alice was writing that i
realized that whoa this wasn't something
that
would be limited to washington and new
york and the big cities and something
that would come across on the network
news but that the crisis was really
percolating down to the local level and
when alice welton started writing those
editorials it was certainly a clear
signal to the democrats who represent
west virginia in congress
that
and to
to all those who might have read them
and there i'm sure there are a lot of
other small towns around the country
where similar editorials were written
that it was time to seriously proceed
with
the investigation
and the house judiciary committee on
nixon and it just seemed to me in
appropriate to symbolize as a
rather than reprint the new york times
or washington post editorials but to
reprint them from a small town weekly we
only have a couple minutes at any time
in this project publishing these
memos and going to the files where you
ever motivated yourself politically
either for or against richard nixon
i'm really trying to to understand him
i've always i
hope i've been fair uh to him through
all of this
sure i've been motivated politically i
mean i'm
an animal who's tries to understand
politics i was
president of my high school senior class
and it was i was also editor-in-chief of
my high school newspaper
so i was playing both sides of the
street at that time and i made a very
conscious decision after that fact that
that i really didn't want to get into
the political uh
debate on one side or the other i
uh
and i have some reservations for
instance about
the idea that's being broadcast by many
conservatives it really originated in
the nixon years that we should have our
politics organized along british lines
that is conservatives on one side and
labor and liberals all on the other side
i think the american tradition uh
has been that
you know there should be an important
moderate element within the republican
party and a more important moderate
element within the democratic party and
that our politics really should be
centrist politics i mean i think that's
the great strength of this country
so uh
no i didn't not have partisan motive i'm
still trying to understand nixon some
things i agree with him on some things i
doubt our guest for the last hour has
been bruce otis as you can see here this
is the sick thick 661
page book published by harper rowe and
it includes many memoranda
from the era of 1969 to 1974 written by
richard nixon and other of his aides
thank you very much for joining us
you're quite welcome
[Music]
that concludes this week's edition of
book notes a reminder to join us for a
re-air of this program monday morning at
6 30 a.m eastern time and coming up next
on c-span a look at the week ahead in
congress
[Music]
[Music]
politicians foreign leaders today